hey guys welcome back to the Spates
waterair dance in France preview show it
is the last round of pool games and
there is some huge matchups knockout
footy has come a week early for some
teams um so a huge round to look forward
to we're going to do a little bit
differently this week We've Got Jake The
Snake Atkins the man from the Northern
Hemisphere who's providing so much
valuable Insight he's going to do the
review and then we've got our man sirle
from sirly talk sport who's going to
come on and do the preview because after
last week's tips Jake The Snake is now
banned from tipping previewing but he is
a guru at his analysis I'm looking
forward to his review of round one
because we all know he tipped out Italy
to beat the all black and lost by 96
points so terrible tipping from you
snake what' you make of that one let's
start there oh but I'm not having this
boys I can get up the receipts to the
record I said it was not going to be a
serious matchup because Italy's defense
was not good enough ALS Al my pick of
Japan over you boys against Samoa
slipped under the radar with that Italy
result as well so I'm I've got myself
two n up against you boys um but yeah I
think surley was so unimpressed with uh
with my chat about Italy that he's
decided he won't speak to me this week
so we've had to split the recording half
or he could still be hung over actually
um but yeah let's crack on with that New
Zealand Italy game like oh geez boys
this was a tough one this is a tough one
I watched this in a bar in Italy
um and like fair play to them like the
fans in the bar still got up and
celebrated that last try and I was I was
watching it with my with my Welsh and
South African teammates and um when they
started celebrating that last try we
were saying like gez if this was back
own the game would have been off at
halim and everyone would have just been
sinking piss um so look fair play from
the Italian fans but on the field yeah I
I don't really know if
I've got the vocabulary to articulate
how much of a hid in that was
Lads like I I I pulled some numbers up
because I think it's easier just to look
at in raw numbers like New Zealand 86
carry meters 33 Defenders beaten so
that's 33 missed tackles 20 line breaks
14 tries 20 line breaks is massive hey
like that is a absolute kic some teams
go through a game without a line break
yeah I've watched England do that for
the last two years
bro um yeah 20 line breaks and like this
was it's been a long long time since
Italy had a hiding like this we're
looking at like 20 years since Italy had
a proper proper Old School hiding like
this and I just think um they were
unfortunate that they just they
sleepwalked into this game against an
all blacks team where this performance
has probably been building in the
background quietly for a long time you
think the the South Africa result coming
into the World Cup and then the France
result round one combined with all the
sort of media talk of like are the boys
a bit under you know writing them off in
the tournament we we spoke last week
about maybe training getting real heated
up this week in the camp um it's
probably a performance that's been
bubbling like like Brewing up for a long
time and then they just absolutely
unloaded on an Italian team that was
half asleep in the first half weren't
they yeah it was an incredible
performance it's one of those ones like
there's not many teams who can beat up a
side like that like when the All Blacks
have front foot ball there's clearly no
better side than them cuz they can they
can score TR like not many other teams
can um I guess the real test is when
they are put under pressure how are
they're going to be able to adapt and
that's going to be the big one when they
come up against Ireland or Scotland or
soare in this quarterfinal um I guess
they get a lot of confidence from it but
um I'm not sure if it's solved many
problems about when they can't get front
foot ball how they're going to be able
to react but um man if teams let them
get quick ball and play a high Tempo
speed the boys can just play they play
the footy and score some unbelievable
tries that game was pretty to watch
especially if you had some fantasy Rie
players out there yeah for sure like
we've spoken a lot about like France
being the maybe the best team coming
into the tournament and Ireland being
the best coached and most organized team
but like unquestionably New Zealand are
the most ruthless and accurate team like
in terms of executing their
opportunities if they get given a
picture for space nine times out of 10
they they absolutely nail it off and I
think that's why we see them so often
like I I've written down about one of
the later games like I think the
difference between the top top sides and
the sort of mid- tier sides is that the
top sides are putting the
minnows to the sword and Italy turned up
and played like a Mino side and New
Zealand put a 100 on them and and that
is where New Zealand are like excellent
best team in the world is they are just
ruthless if you give them if you
give them crap pictures in defense they
just ruthlessly keep taking them all day
um I thought um Jordy coming back into
that side man jeez that backline looks
different with him in the middle mate I
think um yeah I was sitting here
watching I actually said to to the lads
I was watching it with like he he must
be the most allround in terms of
complete player the most all-rounded
footballer in the world like I can't
think of another guy who could start for
a top one two three side in the world
every position in the backline and do a
genuine like test match quality job he's
such an impressive player man I agree
and I think I think it was sirley who
spoke about him in the preview but yeah
him coming back mate you could see the
difference I mean as cross kick early on
in the game to set up the first try and
just has all the skill set and um yeah
looking forward to him getting it one
more game under his Bel before the big
one for them to sort of build to more
combinations but very impressive um game
do you see does it change your opinion
on the um quarterfinal or where does
where does that sit for you I think it
just makes it a tastier matchup um I
think um look realistic like you said it
in terms of their preparation it it
probably wasn't the ideal hit out they'd
have wanted like it's great for the lads
to get confidence and like we said get
some meters in the legs and score a load
of tries but doesn't necessarily Harden
them up the same way that if if we think
they're going to get Ireland the same
way the Ireland have been hardened up
especially Ireland this week looking at
the match up they're coming off you know
they're basically coming off a uh you
know a mini quarterfinal now um so I I
wonder if it you know if it affects
their preparation that way but if I I
would say if there's one team that
doesn't need like a tough run in before
they can just turn up and execute it is
the All Blacks and I think um like for
me and I think a lot of people in Europe
as well it it had really slipped under
the radar that that Jordy had sort of
moved into Midfield and lock that place
down himself in the last 12 months um
and obviously he didn't play against
France and I think now he comes in that
backline does look different the balance
like it's obviously it's one player
coming in and you know he's replacing
another world worldclass player but the
whole balance of the backline looks
better for me now so look Ireland is
still favorites but it certainly makes
the matchup if it needed to be more
exciting it makes the matchup more
exciting now I think it's closer it's
closer to a coin toss than it was before
that's for sure yeah man it is going to
be some quarterfinal cannot wait for man
but we've obviously got a few more games
to get through from the weekend you
spoke about it Japan vers SAR you did
out Japan and this one me and suly both
went s man I was disappointed with S I
thought they were going to fire a few
more shots than they did but um Japan on
the other hand looked sharper I thought
this was their best game they played all
um competition and sets up a pretty
juicy match up this weekend as well so
um where did you see this game no for
sure I really enjoyed watching this game
man I think it was Japan back I'm not
going to say too their best but closer
towards their best you know um that kind
of like ball handling High possession
between the 22s in Midfield that like
intricate interplay down the 15 channels
that we've like come to love to watch
from Japan and I think that the main
thing from Japan that excited me was how
much of a positive step this was from
the England game like the way they
managed this game against Samoa was so
much better you know the first 10 15
minutes they they exited well they were
happy to kick the ball to a to a really
fired up Samoa team and sort of let them
shoot their shot and just get through
and surv that first 15 minutes of of
Samoan heat and then they started to as
the Samoan boys started to get tired
into the game Japan started to expand
play higher possession keep ball alive
more and they had a really really nice
period through the middle of the game
where they' looked close to what we've
come to expect from them at the last few
World Cups where they were really really
impressive to watch at times um I don't
think that the red card should um sort
of like undermine Japan's win I know it
got close at the end but I actually
think Japan will really dominating the
game pre- red card and then after the
red card I actually think they they fell
off a little bit which so sometimes
happens for teams doesn't it just
galvaniz as the other Lads but um for
Samoa like geez their discipline is
absolutely shocking man like another two
cards in this game um and then not just
this game throughout the tournament in
general like at this level against any
tier 2 or tier one side like you just
you cannot be given away that many cards
I think I'm noticing more from the Mino
type sides I feel like their technique
isn't quite as good maybe it's the lack
of rugby they've played coming into the
world cut but all the teams who are
playing less rugby going into these
games seem to be giving away a lot more
cards for these high shots maybe they're
not used to it maybe they're just not um
as focused on it because they've got
more to focus on but um it's costing
them dearly in some of these games
absolutely man I think that there's
there's kind of there's two things that
stick out to me like that seem to be
consistent trends for when the red cards
are one one is like um is like fatigue
like when players get tired and they get
lazy sometimes they revert to that kind
of like old like what we do in training
which is like a square shot on the ball
but when you're trying to Belt somebody
you end up hitting them above the ball
and taking their head off it's almost
that like heavy legs they don't want to
dip into the into the tackle um and then
the other thing is like the emotional
control like you said with with the
minow teams obviously some of them are
getting so pumped up for these games
they lack that kind of like calm
ruthlessness obviously they do they lack
that kind of like calm ruthlessness we
expect of like Ireland where they're
just like dead cool Dead Calm clinical
um and that kind of lack of emotional
control and fatigue often I think is
what results in these plays like no no
players are trying to take someone's
head off it is just a a sort of a brain
fight isn't it yeah 100% agree with all
of that but the next game was Argentina
versus Chile did you get anything out of
this one 595 to Argentina but yeah I I
watched this game I um I think we we've
mentioned sort of lack of depth
affecting the minow teams a lot on the
Pod so far over the last few weeks in
terms of like how it affects them in
game like getting to 50 60 Minutes in
the second half and then watching the
bigger sides run away with it because
the quality we we see Off the Bench I
think this weekend was the first time
we've seen the minow teams getting stung
for their lack of depth like in in terms
of The Wider structure of the World Cup
um you know you think like fronting up
games big test match games week after
week now they're they're just not used
to doing that and they obviously can't
rotate for games like the tier one sides
can and I just think like looking at
this Chile game uh against Argentina
like just it was so obviously laded with
just emotional and physical fatigue like
slipping off tackles like making poor
decisions easy shove over Ms for
Argentina um and yeah I just think it's
that combination of like lack of depth
and then you know like a lot of these
guys aren't in full-time professional
environments like every single player is
in the tier one teams you know you every
single player in that Argentina team is
used to fronting up tough game tough
game tough game in a full professional
training environment week on week and
they've done that for years and years
and I just think it looked now like
Chile is starting too and and some of
the other minow teams we saw in this
round as well just starting to maybe
have exceeded their
limits in terms of freshness like this
is a long tournament and the boys just
look at times yeah now they just
can't quite compete against those teams
um they did hang in there a wee bit in
this one but obviously Argentina ran
away with it but the next game was one
that we spoke about as potentially being
a banana skin and with about 20 to go it
looked like it might have been heading
that way was Fiji RSE Georgia
1712 um even right up to the last minute
chasing that last kick from the Georgian
um fullback or whoever it was um this
game went right down to the wire what
did you make of it yeah I wish I'd had
the balls to pull the trigger on calling
a a banana skin game I I moused out of
it and now I'm really regretting it
because it would have been a hell of a
pick look I mean the the short of it is
it's great to see Georgia turn up at
this tournament like I've I've been sort
of Haring about them um last couple
weeks on the Pod because I I was really
hoping coming into the tournament that
we were going to see like a 2019 2015
style Japan turnout from them especially
looking at their group I was like there
is a couple of matchups there where they
could Nick a Nick a game or two and
potentially upset someone's standings
for the quarterfinals and it's it just
it just hasn't happened for them and
look great performance too little too
late but um Fiji I think um are now in
sort of new territory for them aren't
they where it's like um the the pressure
of expectation like we see them as a
genuine serious team now and that comes
with a whole another load of baggage you
can't necessarily be as emotionally free
when you know that there's genuine
results on the line um but yeah Georgia
did a good job to keep him out but 60 65
minutes and then Fiji do what Fiji do
don't they I mean that the second try
with B like Georgia can defend as well
as they want you can't stop him doing
that and we know that Fiji have like two
or three moments of world class rasle in
them and they're going to put these
sides away and I think it'll be the same
for Portugal this week yeah that's all
it was in that game a couple of moments
of fen magic and um end up being too
good for Georgia but there were some
concerns from that game to think about
the quarterfinal match up with England
um England will be sort of licking their
lips around the way they struggled when
they were put under pressure so um yeah
it's going to be an interesting match up
for for for sure but I do think Fiji
will be far too good um this week going
for forward against Portugal but the
next one was um Scotland who were far
too good for Romania 84 nil Darcy Graham
what an absolute lad he is on the wing
four tries unbelievable stats highest
fantasy score of the year so far so well
done to anyone who played him or
captained him or even triple captained
him but what do you make of the game
obviously I don't know many of those
Scottish second stringers but um gez
like some of them can play yeah and I
think we mentioned it just just a second
ago talking about New Zealand like one
of the big differences at this
tournament between the the top sides and
the mid-table sides is the top sides
put the minow teams to the sword
even when they rotate to their second
string team um you know obviously
Scotland scored heaps and heaps of tries
loads of line breaks but they also shut
them out to zero points which takes some
doing in a test match no matter I don't
care who you play against to nil anyone
in a test match is seriously seriously
impressive and Scotland have shown that
they are now they should be considered
in that higher bracket of International
Teams um you know like we just said they
rotated and they still are ruthless
enough to put these put these smaller
sides away um but you know it I find
myself saying this every week when we
talk about Scotland like they are just
so lucky unlucky on the on the draws
like if they're in two of the other
groups I think they potentially qualify
top seed yeah I agree um and go into it
go into a really favorable quarterfinal
and then you're looking at them like
okay favorable quarterfinal they
probably walk into a semi-final and when
it's semi-final time you know anyone can
beat any one of those top four five
teams so I I just feel so bad for them
in terms of the scheduling situation
that they it just seems so unfair that
they have to try and go and get a result
now against Ireland well if anyone can
beat anyone in those top four or five
teams well then this is the weekend to
show it I guess this is their their
final for them um this is a huge
opportunity I know they confident in
their Camp it does set up a very very
juicy matchup for a pool play um
especially last round of the pool um
with so many different ways of teams
progressing um heard all sorts of um
ways that South Africa can be out or um
Ireland could be out or Scotland could
be out like obviously the they're
working overtime and the points
differential and all those sort of
different options but um end of the day
if Scotland win this is going to be a
huge game for them yeah absolutely huge
and like gez Razzi rasmus's Twitter has
been absolutely fantastic this week man
I don't know if you filmed it but that
guy is so funny man like I totally
understand why he frustrates people he
frustrates me at time but if you're a
player in his Squad man I think you'd
find him so funny yeah like just laying
into people on Twitter tweeting all the
potential scenarios I have to keep
checking it's his real page and not like
a parody
page oh jeez he's good he's good but but
yeah that Scotland Island game this week
man
jeez I think it's uh it's going to be
very very tasty it is for me it's a pre-
quarterfinal like it it is a
quarterfinal match up in the pool play
this week yeah 100% and looking forward
to it okay next one Australia versus
Portugal Australia by 20 I think I TI
that right on the button um I just don't
think Australia are that good um
Portugal are okay and um that game
basically went how I expected it to yeah
Jim hell of a pick from you man like I
mean before before we sat down to start
recording for this world cup if we'd
been set sat in a situation where you're
saying Australia by 20 against Portugal
who I'd never seen play code before yeah
like I I wouldn't have even been able to
grasp a situation and to mate it should
have been less it should have been less
difference Portugal dropped the ball
over the line from a shove over yeah so
you know and they slapped their goals
over so it should you know could have
been
13 um May I like we just said about
Scotland the difference between the top
sides and the Not Top sides is the top
sides are putting the minnows to the
sword absolutely crucifying them and
Australia on't the top side at the
moment it's the it's the harsh reality
of it like I flick through flick through
some of the stats after the game just
flagged up Portugal right more
possession more territory more meters
made more Defenders beaten more offloads
more gain line success better scrum
percentage better lineup percentage
that's almost that's almost every key
metric for Portugal yeah that is
absolutely crazy that we're sat here
saying Portugal have won you know every
single sort of kpi of rugby performance
to Australia I mean positive twist for
Australia they they lost all those key
metrics and still got the result yeah
but um they're genuinely becoming almost
a tier two um Nation aren't they in
terms of the quality of rugby they
player yeah and it was like it was tough
to watch at times man like even some of
their scores was
just drive your way down the field
through kicking and um sort of like
penalty infringements from Portugal get
into the 22 and then just legit smash
over against the smaller side um
Portugal on the other hand man like some
of their structures and their attack
stuff is really really nice man the the
the first score that they put over
against uh against Australia in the 22
now was such great shape such great
shape attacking in that 22 zone is is
sort of like the most difficult place to
run good attack shape isn't it because
you've got 15 defenders in the front
line and the defense is super aggressive
because they can't give up any space so
almost all the time when you get into
that zone teams can't keep to run good
shape but they they were patient they um
kept the backs loaded the whole time
patient patient saw the picture pulled
the trigger and executed brilliant shape
and then three-man cut out both go
untouched on goal line attack is that
that that's what gets me going for goal
absolutely love to see it from a minow
team to be that well organized and that
clutch like have been really really
impressed with the attack shape they've
run this uh this tournament man they've
been um they've been the exciting side
for me coming out of the minnows I think
yeah they've been the surprise package
for me obviously like you I had never
seen Portugal player if you told me
before the World Cup or before they
entered the World Cup I wouldn't even
known they had an international side but
what they've done at this Rugby World
Cup I think they can be really proud of
they've played well played um exciting
footy every week and um even push sides
like Australia to you know relatively
close margins so Portugal um I think
they can leave this Rugby World Cup uh
despite what happens this week um with
their heads out heide and um they got a
few new fans from all around the world
no doubt but the last game was South
Africa vers Tonga and this was a game
which I thought uh deserved to be closer
on the scoreboard than it was I thought
Tonga really put South Africa Under
Pressure um pretty early in this game
and then South AFA just managed to
squeeze a few points from few loose sort
of tries um unusual tries one off the
was it off the head or the shoulder
again yeah the head the head pass again
they learned that from England M that
pass needs to probably come into some
team's facee shape I didn't realize you
could throw it at someone's shoulder
because that seems like you could move
that to give yourself a um benefit of it
the doubt but um you obviously can and
they scored off it and I think that was
a bit of a momentum swing cuz had them
under all sorts of pressure close to the
line the prop got actually penalized for
holding someone in which you don't
usually see usually the ref will just
say don't do that um play the ball but
he got penalized and then they went down
field got that try and that was a big
turning point but um South Africa when
they work their forwards around the
corner and get physical they're a tough
side and they ended up just having too
much power and um impact Off the Bench
to just run away with that one
yeah I think you've absolutely nailed it
there jim I've got very very similar
stuff I think um we mentioned from South
Africa that um in terms of last week
when we did the review we spoke about
their attack just looking a
bit aimless I think is a kind way to say
it at times when they don't win those
first two collisions um and like Tonga
for the majority of this game just
fronted up for those collisions and they
they do just look at times when they get
stuck between the 15s and they're not
winning
s like they run out of ideas there's
almost
no sort of like plan b or like thinking
of moving a team around or changing
shape and changing their structure to
sort of ask questions of a defense or
challenge folds or find attacking kicks
you know they're sort of classic things
that you want to see from a world class
side when they don't win collisions I
think they just they are so used to
winning collisions that the backline has
almost got lured into this false sense
of security that they can almost like
spark up a cigarette let them go to work
and then flop over the line yeah
um positives from this man I think this
was a huge step forward from Tonga from
the week before um I maybe I was a
little bit harsher than when I listened
back to the the review from from last
week's pod but this was uh this was a
really really good step forward for them
the only thing I added other than that
Jim was the South African goal kicking
looked good yeah um I think they went
100% off the te if I got that right yeah
Paul kicked all his and then leot came
on I think he kicked two or three but
yeah I think he kicked two and one from
the touchline and that I think that for
me just reinforces what I mentioned last
week about like this being a
psychological thing for laok in terms of
the the pressure and rushing his process
like the guy can obviously strike a
clean ball I mean he's got one of the
best skill sets in World rugby obviously
he can hit a still ball we saw him hit a
cross kick without looking at it the
other day um he just he's just obviously
under a huge amount of pressure he
probably feels under the pump as well
now poads back in the squad um because
he knows that people will be calling um
polard obviously got the job done for
them in 2019 like we've said South
Africa not just sort of tactically for
their rugly team but like culturally
it's so important for them to have a
kicker who kicks their goals it's just
such an important part of their their
identity as as a as a fan base as well
as a team um and it I think it it does
just show the psychological effect of
like getting in your own way when you
goal kick um so it'll be interesting to
see now what they do they obviously have
a difficult decision to make for
quarterfinal time whether they back a
Bach I think Razzy will he he tends to
go with his guys who've had the Jersey
leading into big games um he tends to
back his boys to come up big and I hope
he does because I want South Africa to
keep pushing this attack forward again
we mentioned last week like this this
this is such a good backline this this
is such a good backline and like we said
could be the best back three in the
world I think Leach is one of the best
ball players at the line I just think
they're cruising through games at the
moment and letting letting the forwards
dictate the game and sort of letting the
game pass them by almost um I mean what
do you think do you think do you think
they'll go with paard I think they will
go with paard uh like I spoke about last
week I just think he suits their style
the way they want to play better Manny
strikes a ball clean off the tea um um I
just feel like that's the style they
want to play and if they're going to
play that way he is the man but I'd also
love to see Le block there because it
would mean they're looking to play a
little bit more use their backline like
we've said and um it's interesting
that's an interesting Dynamic for them
but
um yeah I think if especially if they're
going to look for this um 71 split again
then surely po out your man because
you're looking to play a very Ford
dominated um style of rugby but that is
going to be a matchup as well in that
quarterfinal if that if nothing happens
um too outrageous in the Scotland game
but France South Africa wow he these um
quarterfinals are just next level but
mate that wraps up the review um
incredible Insight from you and I got to
say special shout out to Mint for
providing these Andy vouchers for six
winners last week six people picked will
Jordan to score in the sixth minute of
that game versus Italy so
um I initially only had two vouchers per
week but um shout out to Mint for still
providing six vouchers to all of the
winners I also had a Spam account trying
and get credit credit card details off
some of you guys off the Facebook entry
so apologies for that and I even CED a
fair amount of abuse um from a lot of
people saying that I am a scammer but I
just want to let you know that this is
not a scam it's just a friendly giveaway
who someone's tried to um get on the
back of so um I won't be doing any more
comps through the Facebook page it'll
all come through the Instagram um page
going forward so if you do want to join
the competition this week and win
yourself a mint uny voucher then um head
over to the wet Instagram page and stay
tuned and I'll just give everyone an
update on my fantasy rugby team
obviously had a pretty average round
last week up until the master stroke of
playing and Captain and Darcy Graham
huge turnaround for me got a massive
score highest fantasy score of the comp
so far which meant I did end up going up
a few places to 10th in the water lad
League um some huge scores all around
some people triple captained him um but
it was a good week to have Darcy Graham
in your side my fijians let me down I
got um a couple of cards radradra let me
down with just only a handful of points
and um to over as well a late card cost
him um but it just goes to show your
matchups are important even if you think
um a team is going to win um you need
the team to really win to light up some
points so OB obviously the All Blacks
scored a lot more points than I was
expecting so if you had some All Blacks
on your side then you would have been
happy days but that Scottish backline
was where all the points were and the 84
nil Victory so getting as many of those
backs in your side is really important
which looking forward to this week I
think it's a pretty obvious week for
Fantasy real clear games on who you need
to stack your team with obvious captain
choices as well so your three All Blacks
I think this weekend are going to be key
um your outside backs I'm looking at
Damian McKenzie who's a fantasy Wizard
playing at fullback um I've G will
Jordan tossing up between those two as
Captain and um my last one is probably
going to be ler foku so I'm looking at
the few outsides and they're the guys
who seem to be wrecking up the most
points and I want to make the most of a
big score here against Uruguay I think
you also go go three French three tongin
three fijians in your squad and then you
take your pick on those last three so
that's how I'm going to balance my squad
I'll wait for the teams to be named
before I choose who those players are
going to be but the likes of poo and
stuff stand out against the Italians so
huge week for me fantasy rugby hopefully
climb up into that top five or three for
the water lad league and um see where we
end up so that is the review part of the
show done obviously this is where we say
goodbye to our good friend Jake The
Snake but that means we also welcome in
sirle from sirly talk sport we've
managed to track him down he started the
waterl jingle throughout that whole
second half against um in that all black
game in the weekend but good to have you
on the show for the important part of
the show the preview The Tipping part
how are you mate yeah good mate yeah I
thought I'd show up for the business end
and just try steal the show like you
mentioned I tried to get the jingle
going we had a couple false starts I
thought I heard someone humming it so I
went again for a third go but it wasn't
quite the impact that I wanted there
were a lot of uh French fans dressed up
in all blacks CIT so it fooled me into
thinking that I was surrounded by fellow
kiwi so let's put it down to that you
know not quite as familiar with the
track maybe yeah I thought I heard it
for a moment there but it sounded like
it was in a different language and then
um I ended up noticing it was in sort of
the tune of the French national anthem
as well so it wasn't quite it but it was
pretty
yeah I um actually emailed in to try to
get the lyrics up on the big screen cuz
obviously it's it's quite a tricky song
to master but um they obviously missed
that memo too I did notice though they
kept putting up um in French conversion
means transition so it kept coming up
transition Richie manga and I was
expecting him to come out as a whole new
bloke every time it came up on the
screen so something to keep an eye on
there as well I'll be watching that one
closely but what was the atmosphere like
you obviously at the game what a game to
be at M you needed get to all the all
black games what a difference you make
yeah obviously the boys knew I was there
in attendance and I asked for a cricket
score and they delivered it um for short
of raising the bat but no the atmosphere
was Unreal like the passion that the
French fans have I think I mentioned it
after that opening game but like it's
all blacks vers Italy 20 minutes in you
just the national anthem just Sparks up
out of nowh the French Anthem and they
got like tears in their eyes just
belting it out and Yeah given they've
had a fair few but it's just so cool to
see and then the Italian fans were so
into it as well and despite them getting
smoked they were still well and truly
into it and then you had the kiwis doing
what kiwis do best and that's just TR
start Mexican waves left right and
Center that's how we we have our pres
and a couple of them went around the the
full time a few rotations so there were
some BLS that were fizzed you know they
looked like they were from you know your
Hamilton and theil type of operators and
they were just stoked to be there you
could tell but no it was a great crowd
mate right it sounds awesome and
obviously they're going to be there's
going to be another good one this
weekend when New Zealand take on
Uruguay um they if they can put on 96
against Italy it's hard to see this one
being much less where are you seeing
this game going it's going to be
interesting right obviously there's
quite a few changes here I think only
six Lads are starting from that game
against Italy so en Foster's taken a
slightly different approach to what a
lot of people might have thought I do
think it's a fine line right between
building towards the quarterfinal and
also resting a couple guys that have
probably played more minutes than
expected coming in I think that loss
against France kind of forced our hand
to play a really strong side against
nibia for at least a portion of that
game and as a result we're seeing them
rest this week but I'm not sure if we'll
clock 96 I think that's a pretty tough
task like I was just blown away by that
all blacks performance I'm sure you and
snaky have talked about it already but I
was thinking 40 points and then it was
it was more than that at half time so
I'm thinking around you know 60 plus
would be a good result here it's more
around like the style that we play and
guys that are On The Fringe looking to
push for a spot in the 23 like your lers
and Co if they can do enough here to
convince Foster that they need to be in
that lineup next weekend for me but
what's your thoughts on this game CU
it's one of those ones if you win by 40
or 50 but you don't play well everyone
gets nervous again yeah it's interesting
and I'm not sure about the selection um
decision either it doesn't really make
for me I'd be expecting them to try and
get the best combinations going into
this final as possible uh potentially
trying one or two things that they think
could um be make a little bit of a
difference but I was surprised to see so
many changes like um to rest some of
these guys they've played like 80
minutes over four weeks um feels like
that there's no real need to rest them I
guess the threat of an injury but that's
that's just footing I feel like we've
got enough depth to be able to replace
basically anyone
so uh yeah interesting I'm not too sure
I do think it's going to be a massive
score um I do feel like the All Blacks
when they get quick ball they're just an
incredibly hard team to to face and
they've got so much X Factor across the
park um dmac at fullback excites me I
think he's going to have a massive day
I've just spoken about him and my
fantasy team will Jordan I feel like
it's going to be a huge day at the
office for the these types of guys
Richie moang he's had a relatively quiet
Rugby World Cup so far I'm expecting him
to put on a put on a Richie Mo show
which um we know he can do double time
lad s Medal winner um he's got the
reputation that when he comes to the big
games and this is mainly building into
next week he is going to be stepping up
but I'm looking forward to him giving us
a little um teaser of what he can do at
this Rugby World Cup and I just I do
think it's going to be 80 plus I just
can't re the scores seem to go up pretty
quick um when you're watching the game
even that 96 it felt like they did that
relatively easy just never really had
rough patches but um yeah I think it's
going to be a huge score again Uruguay
aren't quite the side Italy are and uh
yeah I'm expecting another big big score
no it was interesting to hear Ian Foster
though speak I don't know if you heard
it today but he mentioned DX starting
and then he's going to move into 10 and
bod will come on into 15 which I found
kind of interesting because like bod's
100% back now in their eyes right I
thought they might have kept Damian
there bod at 10 or maybe even move will
to the back but it's so clear now that
bod's stuck in that 15 Jersey he could
be a great option off the bench at 10
but clearly they've ruled that out so
it's interesting to get the insight into
that as well so like you mentioned I
think Damian's in for a huge day on
fantasy I've got him for two or more
tries on my bet slips as well so I think
he could run a mar yeah well that is
that is great Insight from you to make
sure that uh Damen McKenzie is is the
choice over Richie manga at 10 this
weekend um for fantasy players because
um you're getting that extra game time
and when that move does happen he's
going to I mean he's got he's a Fantasy
wizard anyway his game um a lot of his
game is fantasy points has a lot of
fantasy points in it so um getting that
Insight from you he's moving to 10 bod
to fullback um points Gore for him um so
that could even be a good Captain an
option for a lot of people out there um
good from you into the um fuzzy press
conferences well done you got to one
okay next game France V Italy Now France
beat New Zealand
so New Zealand uh France are going to
beat Italy by
120 or what did they beat us by um how
do you see this game going yeah
unfortunately that math didn't work out
for that W's game last week did it but
yeah this is an interesting one and
great to see the Italians kind of saying
they targeted this game instead of the
All Blacks game after all that bent they
ricken there up for the upset this week
but to be honest mate like no one's
talking about this game here this week
they're all talking about your Island
vers Scotland and those type of matchups
so I think this one's kind of flying
under the radar a bit and the only time
you hear about the French team on
national news is just daily Dupont
updates which is fair enough too I guess
cuz they've got this game in the bag
don't they I expect Italy to be a bit
better like they'll be so disappointed
at that performance they really built it
up the coach asked them to go the big
lift to try and get them that one win
against his old kiwi side but yeah I
expect them to be better but I do think
France by 60 to 80 points I don't think
it'll be that that 96 but I still think
it's going to be incredibly
one-sided I just want to see Italy start
well like I thought they'd at least do
that last week I thought the first 20
minutes they just come out full of
passion like you saw them in the anthem
they were giving it the big ones to them
just drop away like that was so
disappointing so hopefully they can
start well but the battle of the anthems
that's worth the price of admission
alone like whoever wins that could go a
long way to winning the game mate M 80
points is still a huge score so I do
think I think this is either going to go
one or two ways I think Italy will keep
it relatively close like they've
obviously been a huge improver in the
Six Nations snaky took them up this
whole preview show um everyone says
they're a serious side now obviously in
the weekend was the biggest loss they've
ever had in about 20 years like they're
better side than that I think everyone
knows that so it's either going to be a
competitive game where they really turn
up and stay in the fight for a long time
or they've just lost so much confidence
from that loss in the weekend that um
poo and the likes run an absolute muck
in this game and I'm expecting maybe the
second a little bit like you I could see
this going 60 to 80 pretty easy and um
France just show everyone that they are
still potentially the team to beat next
game Wales versus Georgia so Georgia
came off a good result against Fiji
played a lot better push them all the
way can they beat Wales I think this
game's going to be a lot closer than
everyone's predicting I think Georgia
might be able to push Wales a little bit
here yeah I tend to agree and I think
what Georgia bat them last time they
played or or recently anyway so it's an
interesting matchup because Georgia's
strengths also help nullify Wales like
they play a kind of similar game where
the four packs just go at it right so I
think Georgia will really be up for this
one and they got that confidence from
last week they were disappointed that
they couldn't pull it off but they
really pushed FG and he and snaky were
messaging through the night no doubt y
misso was wondering what was going on on
WhatsApp mate she probably thought you
were up to no good but we were Bing God
for
Sleep smart man yeah we were bantering
about how we said it could be a banana
skin we didn't think it would be but it
looked like it was going to be again so
it's hard to know what you're going to
get with Georgia again they're another
of these sides that fuel So High On
Emotion but I think it'll be a win for
Wales and it'll be a 13 plus win but on
the lower side of that like I'm thinking
yeah 20 25 points good to see Dan
Biggers set to come back for them next
week he reckons and enum he's so good
anyway he'll pull the strings there's
been a few changes though so yeah I'm
expecting a 20 to 25.1 but I see some
people saying Wales or Waltz through I
don't think Wales are potentially as
strong as the Wes made them look so I
think Georgia will push them more than
Aussie did almost yeah I think that's
the trap a lot of people have fallen
into on that poll thinking that if you
beat the wallabies you're you're a good
side but um I think we've shown in this
world cup that that's not the case and I
I genuinely think this is a game which
could be an upset I do think Georgia
could push Wells and I don't know what
that would do to the pool but it would
make it definitely interesting but uh I
am predicting Wales to win but just by a
small margin but don't be surprised if
the Georgians get up for this one and um
change a few results going into this
quarterfinal matchup and the next game
is England versus Samar so Samar been
very disappointing um this whole world
cup really um but this is a chance for
them to go out with a bang and um stir a
few thing uh stir a few feathers but
what do you make do you think there a
chance to beat England I think some are
are most dangerous when they have
nothing to lose right right like
obviously I think I've been saying every
week I've been disappointed with them
just cuz on paper they're such a strong
side but I think with nothing to lose
this is where SAR could do their best
work I'd love to see them beat England
now that snake is not on this call I can
say that I'm not enjoying watching
England play footy at all unless Marcus
Smith is in the football side and I
don't think he will be starting this
week anyway I think they'll go back to
Old mate boring old George Ford but I
I'd love to see some get the win
hopefully W has found his kicking tea
and he's back in the mixer um because
that'll be a massive part of them
getting the result but it would be great
for them to finish on a high because I
feel like if they get dusted 13 plus
here it would seem like a massive semi
like failure disappointing World Cup for
them they would have wanted to have
beaten Japan they probably had hopes of
pushing Argentina and beating them as
well so they're a bit of better football
side I think than their results have
suggested so far so I'll be well and
truly backing s Mo with my heart my head
says England will win they'll go up in
threes and make it a bit more of a
boring Clash but I'm hopeful and if
england proved me wrong then well done
to them as well because I'd like to see
them play some good code as well yeah
I'm looking forward to that game I think
it's going to be an entertaining one
nonetheless and um yeah hopefully SAR
can show us what they can do in this
competition but I like you I'm expecting
England to be too strong um at set piece
and just control this game turn it into
a bit of a strangle Fest and win by
roughly 15 would be my prediction but
the next game the game of the round one
of the games of the pool knockout footy
we've spoken about it already but um
quarterfinals come early pretty much
with Ireland V
Scotland first best team in the world
against the fifth best team in the world
probably um who are you picking did can
Scotland do it can they cause an upset
they certainly can I don't know if they
will but like that's to me is being the
perfect game to finish on like as a fan
this is what you want from your Rugby
World Cup game I think this one in the
Japan Argentina like you want pool
results to not be guaranteed heading in
and this is the perfect matchup there's
been banter flying all week between
these two sides I obviously know each
other really well there's even been
media asking if the Scotland and Ireland
are going to rig it so that South Africa
don't go through which is Elite level
match fixing you'd expect that in some
Rogue cricket league but I rate the
question anyway and it's certainly got
people talking but it's good to see Finn
Russell in the media saying he'll be up
for a bit of buff if it goes that way as
well that's my boy that's that's what
you love to hear from Finn but I think
on the day Scotland could do it I think
they haven't beaten them in the last
eight games since 2017 or something but
they've always been pretty close so it
hasn't been like crazy margins I think
the last time they lost was in that 1
to7 margin so I'd love to see Scotland
do it just because I'm a big fan of the
way they play but I'm also a big fan of
the way isand play and I think they just
problem solved too easily that they'll
get the job done so I'm backing irand
but I think it'll be like under 10
points Maybe by six let's say and I
think they'll just be too classy towards
the back end of the game but Scotland
have the weapons to do it yeah man it
will be it'll throw the competition
right open if Scotland um do win this
game by the points they need to go
through and either Ireland or South
Africa gone out of no where jeez it
would really shock the competition but
yeah I can't quite see it happening
either I like you I rate Ireland far too
highly and um yeah I do feel for
Scotland but um they've showed us how
good they are throughout this world cup
it's been awesome to see them smash the
minow teams and just really show the
world what a quality footy team they are
and I hopefully they put in a really
good performance just to show everyone
that even though they're potentially out
in pool play they're still potentially
the fifth best side or fourth best side
in the world so um yeah just quickly on
that as an all blacks fan are you almost
hoping Island win just so they don't
come into that game next week off the
back of a loss like they could be even
more deadly then would we rather catch
them what 17 18 wins on the Trot and
like obviously it's a knockout game but
maybe a tiny bit of complacency do we
play them if they win uh I would say so
Scotland have to beat them by 21 and not
get a a bonus Point yeah yeah oh hell
that would throw it right open yeah not
sure I think i' rather than win then and
just knock them when they when we need
them to but the next game is Japan V
Argentina um do you see an upset in this
one yeah an upset in terms of I don't
even know who's going to win anyway so
it's hard to know but like Argentina are
short favorites are they that's
interesting because Japan last week
really impressed me I'd been off them
but I thought they were good against
some more and it's another type of
matchup again where they come in heavy
underdogs and they could pull this off I
don't think Argentina are the team they
used to be but at the same time if they
click then I think they'll account for
Japan so it's hard to know what to
expect going into this one I think
Argentina by 10 to 15 points but I also
wouldn't be surprised if Japan get them
by three and it's a complete boilover
and they go through I'm just excited to
see like two sides that play So
differently with so much on the line
they can both be extremely passionate
and emotional just go at it and I'd love
to see Argentina hit the heights of what
they have in the past cuz I think if
they can get through then a semifinal
isn't unrealistic for them just because
of the side of the draw they're on so
it's pretty crazy to think right but who
have you got in this one yeah I I think
Argentina I thought that early like when
we went through those um predictions the
week before to come up with our final
quarterfinalist but like you Japan
impressed me in the weekend I didn't
expect them to beat Samoa um like they
did and then obviously this weekend I
haven't been impressed with
Argentina but um if I think if that
Japan side turned up turns up that did
in the weekend then they're going to
really test this Argentina side and put
them under a fair bit of pressure so I
could see this game also going either
way but I am leaning towards Argentina I
do think they just have a few more um
standout players to get them across the
line but um that's going to be another
cracking match up I'm looking forward to
watching that one okay two more we got
Tonga vers Romania did Tonga just put
away way Romania like everyone else has
in this yeah I think so I thought Tonga
were really good last week I'm sure
you've already spoken about it but that
was their best performance so far that
was the kind of Tonga we wanted to see
throughout the tournament so I think
they're just hitting their straps late
um and I expect them to be well and
truly too good hopefully in like that 30
plus margin it would be cool to see them
in the tournament on such a high and
just show everyone that with more games
they could be a real Force but how about
yourself yeah I'm seeing it the same I
think this is going to be quite a big
score so I am going to try and get three
tongin in my fantasy R beside because I
do think they'll be too good for Romania
I think there's a big gap between those
two sides and yeah we spoke about Tonga
vers South Africa I thought they're
really good competitive they physical
side um and I think when they get some
front football we'll see a a bit more
from the likes of Pi and some of their
dangerous backs have been shut down a
fair bit um throughout this world cup
haven't been able to show um the full
range of skills that they have but in
this game I think we'll see that and I
think we'll Tonga will be able to leave
this Rugby World Cup um feeling pretty
confident that they've done a good job
against Romania well that's where I'm
seeing it anyway and when I say things
like that they're usually right as you
know okay last game is Fiji vers
Portugal um now this is going to be a
good one as well I think Fiji obviously
struggled in the weekend um with Georgia
but I think Portugal should be a more
suitable game for them really both teams
like to play a lot looser style of footy
and which should suit the fijians and I
think they're going to put on quite a
big score on this one and I'm going to
that quarterfinal with a bit of
confidence how are you seeing it yeah
I'm expecting a 13 plus one obviously
they just need the one point to get
through so when will be enough and it'll
be interesting to see like how early
they rotate the bench if they've got the
result one because for me it's that
starting 15 for fij that can win them a
quarterfinal game the bench probably
isn't as strong as the other nations so
protecting those stars at all costs will
be huge but yeah I just think they'll be
too big and powerful through the
Midfield and the offload game is just
going to kill them plus their breakdown
work continues to be unreal it was great
to see their uh assistant coach I think
it was saying to Eddie Jones that
they'll use his credit card to buy some
Carver to celebrate the win this week
I'm sure Eddie's got plenty on the
credit card because we all know the bank
balance probably isn't struggling like
the side is but it's some good ban from
the fijians and I'm just Fizz that I
just really want them to get the job
done just so that it's confirmed they're
in because what a result man and then
they can look ahead to like an angland
or something like that where they've got
nothing to lose but everyone apart from
English fans will be behind them which
will make for such a cool atmosphere
that's almost like the quarterfinal game
you're looking forward to the most
behind that all blacks Island game and
it's just for a complete passion reasons
right yeah man it is going to be an
unbelievable game and I I can't see them
not getting one points so I'm sure Fiji
will go through but I did read that um
TS overa um his son died um before that
Georgian game so incredibly sad news
there the fact that he's managed he's
decided to stay there in the Rugby World
Cup is um quite hard to quite hard to
believe really obviously got a son who's
seven years old and make the thought of
losing a son um and having to go out
there and play footy is um incredibly
tough but he obvious did it this what it
his country means to him and um yeah
this world cup is that important so um
pretty crazy stuff pretty powerful but
condolences to the um tour over family
cuz man that is incredibly sad news yeah
100% And yet like you mentioned the fact
he's staying on is pretty crazy because
something like that can be completely
lifechanging so hopefully at least the
fugan can put in a big performance this
weekend and on they March cuz there'll
be nothing better than seeing them get
the win but yeah that was just
heartbreaking to read you almost have
tears in the eyes reading the story let
alone going through that yourself so how
he managed to get through that game
alone is just crazy yeah get up the
fijians to um at least yeah to make that
all that sacrifice all worth i' love to
see them go as far as they can even to a
final or imagine if they won the thing
it would be absolutely incredible but
imagine all blacks vers VG I'd actually
be quite nervous for the first time ever
to play FG like that's how good they're
going yeah it would be good stuff but um
that does wrap up this round and
obviously next weekend is where it's all
starting to ramp up that whole whole lot
more so really looking forward to next
week leading into this the finals footy
is going to be next level so hope you
enjoy the footy mate and um look forward
to catching up to you next week when
you're back on New Zealand Shores yeah
sounds good mate and hopefully uh snaky
did quite well in the review because
geez he had a pretty tough week didn't
he tipping Italy yeah we've spoken about
it he's had a shocker you love it clip
that up for sure make the man pay a make
him pay up the southern hemisphere hey
guys thanks for listening and if you've
got this far I'm guessing you enjoyed
the episode so if you did please give it
a share if you can and also cheers to
our mates at Spates for sponsoring this
episode